[Musique]
c'est un amant fondamental parce que
l'impensé de la réforme du gouvernement
c'est la démographie
[Musique]
un régime par répartition c'est un
régime justement de transition
démographique et intergénérationnel les
femmes sont déjà les grandes perdantes
puisque vous l'avez tous souligné les
maires de famille encore plus puisqu'on
écrase les trimestres de majoration avec
les deux années de recul c'est quelque
chose de fondamental on ne peut pas
penser l'avenir notre régime sans une
politique familiale qui soit une
politique familiale vraiment vigoureuse
et volontaire et 5% de surcotte sont en
mieux sont une atténuation de ce que
nous propose le projet de loi on est
bien d'accord sauf que c'est moins
que ce que les femmes ont aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui une femme captait
arrive à l'âge légal de la retraite
c'est-à-dire à 62 ans avec tous ces
trimestres si elle décide volontairement
de travailler jusqu'à 64 ans elle aura
10% de surcottes et en plus et en plus
elles ont pas le choix j'allais le dire
Raymonde voilà parce que on vit plus
longtemps et donc d'une certaine façon
il n'y a pas besoin de sortir de
Polytechnique pour comprendre qu'il faut
faire plus rien n'est plus faux rien
n'est plus faux parce que encore une
fois je vous le répète vous raisonnez
sur des moyennes et en statistique ça
n'a pas de sens la moyenne est une
valeur générale ce qui compte c'est
l'écart à la moyenne et l'écart à la
moyenne il est complètement différent en
fonction du sexe et en fonction de la
catégorie sociale et en fonction du
revenu donc faire comme si la moyenne
concernait tout le monde c'est
complètement faux
certains sont directement touchés et
impactés et faire croire comme le
gouvernement que cette réforme est une
réforme de bon sens c'est justement un
non-sens statistique une erreur
politique et une erreur sociale
[Musique]